Speaker 1: All right.
I have a few things today to catch you up
on, first and foremost.
We have been waiting to see what happens in
Georgia with the subpoenas of Republican Senator
Lindsey Graham and Trump's former lawyer,
Rudy Giuliani, with Rudy Giuliani.
His lawyer recently told the judge in New
York he is not fit to travel for medical reasons.
He can't fly down to which the judge said
there's other ways to get down to Atlanta.
You could take a Uber, you can take a car.
There's other ways to get down there.
You could take a train that is pending with
Rudy Giuliani.
However, yesterday, Lindsey Graham or Wednesday,
rather, Lindsey Graham was supposed to show
up at a courthouse in Fulton County and he
did not.
46 news from Atlanta reporting Senator Lindsey
Graham, a no show at scheduled Fulton County
court appearance.
This is what we know right now.
Lindsey Graham didn't show up.
He was subpoenaed to testify in a special
grand jury investigation looking at whether
Trump and others broke laws when they tried
to overturn the results of Joe Biden's win
in Georgia in 2020.
Lindsey is one of the people Trump allies
that the district attorney, Fanny Willis,
wants to question.
Graham said previously he would fight the
subpoena.
His attorneys say the probe is politically
motivated and Graham was indeed ordered to
testify on August 2nd.
The petition states that the state of Georgia
will pay travel expenses and witness fees.
Lindsey didn't show up.
Now, this thing of political motivation, this
is another one of their catch alls that they're
using and hopefully it won't be allowed to
stand.
The idea what they want us to hear when they
say this is politically motivated is there
is no empirical or factual basis to even be
doing this when they go.
These are politically motivated investigations.
They want you to believe the person doing
the investigation is so blinded by political
bias that they are investigating or prosecuting
or doing or subpoenaing on the basis of their
political beliefs, not on the basis of their
responsibility as law enforcement and prosecution.
Of course, that's absurd.
But more importantly, these are alleged political
crimes.
If you try.
To overturn an election.
And have the guy who lost, given the electoral
votes that is politically motivated, even
though Biden won.
You're a Republican and Trump's a Republican
and you want Trump to be president.
It's fundamentally political.
And so it really loses its value to say that
the investigation is political.
Well, if you mean that it's not based on fact,
we can talk about that.
But writing it off as politically in the political
sphere has no meaning whatsoever when these
are politicians trying to achieve political
wins through subterfuge and potentially criminality.
And that's what's being investigated.
They were politically motivated actions that
they took.
And this is the same Republican projection
that we've been following for a long time.
I did something bad that was politically motivated.
And then when you investigate, I'll say you
were doing this based on political motivation.
It's sort of like Democrats are going to commit
fraud and try to take an election that the
voters don't really want them to win.
Well, actually, that's what you're doing.
Joe Biden won and you were trying to take
an election that the voters didn't actually
want you to win.
And I would just write it off as as pitiable.
Except this stuff is really effective.
This stuff is effective.
I mean, in the aftermath of the 2020 election.
Nearly 60% of Republicans fell for it and
they believed actually Donald Trump won.
We've been talking about how effective these
silly things are in the context of Herschel
Walker.
Herschel Walker is the speaking of Georgia,
the Senate Republican nominee in Georgia facing
off against the incumbent Senator Raphael
Warnock.
And Herschel Walker doesn't want a debate.
And I understand why, because Herschel Walker
can't speak.
And so Herschel Walker is now starting to
say, Warnock won't debate me.
And it's so predictable and it's so pathetic
and it's so absurd.
But it works because the Trumpists here warnock's
the one who won't debate and they will believe
it, and they will repeat it, and they won't
allow it to dissuade them from voting for
a guy, Herschel Walker, in November, who quite
literally cannot explain anything.
He cannot explain his view on anything.
He can't speak.
So sadly, it's working for the right to say
these are politically motivated investigations,
even if it means absolutely nothing